depuis la loi notre voter en 2015 les
départements de nouvelles compétences
elles forment quatre grandes familles le
principal volet de l'action du
département concerne le social aide
sociale à l'enfance qui s'occupe des
enfants maltraités mais aussi de la paix
ni la protection maternelle et infantile
sur le suivi des grossesses et des
jeunes enfants agrément pour les
adoptions crèche ou encore maison de
retraite
il assure également un revenu minimum
aux personnes éligibles à l'allocation
personnes âgées et personnes handicapées
pour les actifs il permet l'accès au
revenu de solidarité active ainsi que
l'accompagnement vers le retour à
l'emploi
le département entretient les 1500 75 km
de routes départementales développent de
nouveaux axes de circulation et
participe aux grands projets
d'infrastructures dans les yvelines la
ligne de tramway t6 qui passe par vélizy
et va jusqu à viroflay ou encore le
projet eole pour rapprocher la gare
saint-lazare de mantes la jolie par
exemple
dans le secteur de l'éducation le
département des yvelines s'occupe de 145
collège public entretient équipements
numériques cantine personnel technique
et même le financement de la
construction de nouveaux établissements
dernière grande compétence du
département l'aménagement du territoire
qui englobe plusieurs sujets cela va du
soutien en commune pour des projets
d'aménagement la gestion de l'eau la
protection des espaces naturels
sensibles
ils sont au nombre de 64 dans les
yvelines l'aménagement de sentiers de
randonnée aire de pique nique piste
cyclable au financement du service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
le département doit enfin garantir
l'accès au très haut débit sur son
territoire ajoutez à cela le département
partage aussi des compétences avec la
région le tourisme la culture ou encore
les animations sportives
si compétences au total qui montre
l'importance du tandem entre les deux
collectivités pour le territoire